someone has saved a lot of plants what
are the plans so a year ago when I was
an intern my old boss Cody was religious
about us watering the plants he's very
organized always prepared for every job
and just constantly on top of everything
I created an Excel spreadsheet he would
come in on weekends and one of the
plants himself and actually put his name
on the Excel spreadsheet if we didn't
water the plants he liked message us
individually being like hey did you
water the plant
I definitely feared my job a few times
now that I'm no longer an intern it's
time to get him back so we bought the
exact same three dead plants and swapped
them out with the live ones the intern
ricky has taken over watering the plants
for the last few months and he has no
idea what's about to happen we set up
hidden cameras pretending to film other
videos and miked up all the desks I've
been dreaming about pulling this prank
on Cody for the past six months okay so
we just swapped out the live plans for
the dead ones and we got Lena a head of
the art department to go in and let Cody
know that his plants are dying I was
looking at these guys out here and they
kind of look like I haven't been watered
in a while so I was just like
according our linear he's water in the
pastor Ricky
plans man-made up the water I mean they
look pretty pretty bad I don't know just
why they were green and now they're old
like all the plants are brown as per the
whole schedule got Ricky the past three
days
look here look
so Ricky just walked outside and is
looking at the alive plans and is super
confused at what is going on three
healthy fun chapter and the three that
we saw two minutes ago or somewhere else
yes
hey Cody does not appear to be coming
outside of their time to see the dead
plant so we just sent Andrew the head of
the department to go up to him and say
something hey dude have you seen a plan
either totally Brown
Cody your interns are sweet all right so
I'm super happy with the way this prank
turned out ironically I think this ended
up being more of a prank on brick he'd
thought my head explode they kept play
flipping it was insane my brain really
has like a blip in it like I need to see
like a neurologist but I still pray Cody
that was my goal at the end very
elaborate but that's work you guys
pulled it off
why do you feel like they need to stay
alive